[Music]
you were listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen Bomb happy New
Year I'm an unoriginal bastard but I'm
saying it happy New Year everybody says
happy new happy New Year Ryan happy New
Year Michael I mean what else are you
gonna say I guess what what are you
going to do uh we're back we're back
which means uh thanks to you guys and
the support that you've given us if
you're here for Tom Ellis stick around
and uh I hope you don't fast forward
stuff and you enjoy the interview and
you follow us
uh and uh subscribe our socials are
Ryan uh inside ofy pod on Twitter yes
inside podcast on Instagram and Facebook
that's true that's true and if you want
to support the podcast more there's
Patron p a t o n patreon.com inside of
you to support the podcast like all
these patrons have done Ryan uh without
them without patrons my lovable patrons
who get their names shouted out at the
end of every episode and get a lot of
perks and prizes and things and love and
not notes without them I wouldn't be
here and this is uh really um I really
appreciate you guys um so happy New Year
a lot has has happened you went off to
Hawaii that yep that's where I had my
holidays you had your holidays which
were mix of probably fun stress and uh
you know but at the end of the day it is
uh it's Hawaii I got to go in the ocean
on New Year's Day why not why not ha why
not great why not you were in desert yes
yeah I was uh I had back surgery during
the holidays um on the 18th I believe of
December and it's been rough and
um you know my surgeon thinks
everything's fine so I'm not worried but
you know you saw how swollen I am and
it's like I have a tail back there or
something it's pretty rough so I'm just
trying to go with the flow and waking up
is not easy uh then I start to feel
better mhm and I go in stages but um
anyway I'm just uh glad I can walk and
hopefully things will will continue to
amarate become better word of the Year
word word of the Year folks amarate
already doing it amarate um I hope you
guys had a wonderful holiday I really do
and um thanks for making this podcast
your podcast or one of your podcasts
that you listen to it means the world to
me we've got great guests if you didn't
get to here the caner Reeves dog Star
Episode or um we've had so many great
ones Jennifer Love huitt we've got Tom
Ellis today from Lucifer who was just
wonderful had him in the house and uh it
was fun he's a tall guy didn't realize
he was that tall oh Tommy Ellis Tommy
you're tall
buddy um but uh thank you thank you so
much for everything and want to give a a
a little um reminder Kristen Ritter is
going to be live with me live podcast at
the Regent Theater downtown Los Angeles
December and I believe that's December
20 or sorry January 24th January 24th
Kristen Ritter and me live there's VIP
tickets available go to my link Tree in
my Instagram at the Michel rosenbom get
tickets it's going to be so much fun I'm
going to get one of those t-shirt guns
where you shoot t-shirts out to people
like last time like last time it almost
uh hurt someone yeah it's a dangerous
thing it is but I'm very careful for as
much fun as it is MHM I'm careful yeah
you wore goggles I wore goggles I was
careful so you were safe can't say much
for everyone in the front row but yeah
you were safe but have a cocktail watch
a live podcast there's Q&A there's a VIP
meet and greet before the show um and uh
get tickets now on my link tree at the
Michael rosenbom on Instagram and uh by
the way there's tons of cool merch on
the inside of you online store and I
know this is probably a little longer of
an intro but it's the beginning of the
year so you can listen to it um send in
a lot of Patron boxes today by the way
so I'm going to write a lot of notes to
people of thank you notes because that's
what the top tiers get they get a box
from me with goodies every couple of
months right nice yeah yeah that's right
they also get a bonus episode which we
put on Patron which you and I are going
to do after this yes we are yes so um
that's it really that's all I have the
inside of you uh online store great
merch Smallville stuff scripts blah BL
blah BL blah lot of special guests
coming up we got Katie sack off we got
uh you know who we
got um Edward
Furlong yes boy did he open up man oh
man I love Eddie Eddie Furlong he was
really good uh we have a lot of great
guests coming up I can't even tell you
how many awesome guests are coming so
stay tuned uh it's going to be a great
year it's going to be a great year for
you
I know it so just try to do uh you know
treat yourself right be good to yourself
and try to be healthier and happier and
be good to yourself all that stuff Ryan
right let's just try I'm stifling a burp
but yes let's do you know stifle the
burp man stifle or let it
out there you go let it go uh that's it
man let's get into it um lots to talk
about with Tom Ellis let's get inside of
Tom Ellis it's my point of view you're
to inside of you with Michael Rosen
[Music]
bomb inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience so the coffee is good I
I made you some coffee yes thank you
very much in a chich and Chong mug as
well which is you're uh a pro you're
Welsh well you're born in Wales I was
born in Wales and I am when it comes to
rugby well
uh and I you know I say that I'm Welsh
but I moved from the from Cardiff into
England when I was like 2 years old CU
my dad was a pastor so we moved around a
fair amount when I was a kid yeah what's
that about like I read that your sister
your uncle your dad are all baptist
ministers that's correct yeah are they
still uh my dad is retired my uncle is
retired now and my
sister uh is no longer doing but she
still attends the same church that she
was a pastor at but they had to make
some changes during covid is that pretty
religious Baptist minister is that like
I I I feel like look I'm like I'm not
very religious at all so I you know I
believe in God but I don't know what's
the most religious or where on that
spectrum is the extremeness of it yeah I
well I mean I think Baptist in the
states means something very different
when people think about baptist they
think about the southern baptist
movement which is you know Evangelical
kind of like you know falling on the
floor and having big loud songs prise
Jesus people all of that stuff and that
isn't what the Baptist Church in the UK
was like the Baptist Church in the UK
was much more like a conservative you
know my my Sunday morning would be going
every most people would be dressed in
suits that we'd be sing hymns to an
organ um and you know we got a bit
Progressive during my time there my mom
started the m a music group uh where we
played you know electric guitars I
played the drums
my mom was a Pianist and a and a flute
player um is your mom with us yes yes
she is with you yeah um that's good she
is that' be very awkward awkward if yeah
no but basically yeah it was not it was
not the kind of connotation of Baptist
that we know over in the states very
much sort of um I mean for want of a
better word it was quite boring was it
yeah were you a did they tolerate
cursing not par there was not a lot of
cursing in my house when I was GR gr up
no no nothing you couldn't even say damn
could you I mean I could say stuff like
that but I certainly wouldn't say if I
said oh my God that would get frowned
upon I think that changed I think my
parents sort of evolved as well as we
got older yeah but I think to start with
and certainly you know thinking about my
dad's parents his mom in particular they
very strict in terms of like what you
could and couldn't say and how you
should be as a person um yeah yeah you
know I couldn't even say she in regards
to my mother in reference to my mother
if I go well she's said we don't refer
to your mother as she I'm like well her
no we don't use uh pronouns a phrase in
our house where if you said she the my
mom would go who's she the cat's mother
it was like this weird little thing that
she would say but anyway so were you
guys uh was was there a lot of
discipline were you like you know uh you
know was it was it or was it more a
liberal like you know there wasn't
spanking cuz I was spanked as a kid yeah
no we didn't we didn't ever have that at
all no rulers on the knuckles none of
that no I mean my parents were I felt
like my parents were strict to a certain
point but again as you know I've got a
twin sister and we've got an elder
sister who's a couple years older than
me and then my younger sister is a
couple years younger than me and my twin
and I think as we sort of like hit our
teenage years one thing my parents did
do was they they encouraged us to be
independent right um and through that
Independence we started mixing with
other people you know not in the circles
that my parents would mix in and I think
through that process they kind of like
slackened the Reigns as it were and they
they evolved with us so I you know I I
mean I would go out drinking when I was
like 15 16 and that was okay i' got the
pub I mean it's not like they condoned
it but they also didn't stop me from
doing it you know I was that when like I
had friends that would get grounded you
know that phrase the term you used
grounded you're grounded for two weeks
and it's like we never had any of that
at all it was it was I think that they
just installed in us a trust that we
would do the right thing in any
situation would be in yeah you seem like
a like you know I I heard this from like
of course I text Tom Welling m i text
Amy
Garcia and I mean it was just like you
know honestly I was like Tom come on
like this guy's that nice it's like like
I hope if someone asked about me you'd
be like he's great he's giving he's got
a big heart but you know he could be a
little bit of a dick sometimes I mean we
could all be dicks but like nothing like
like Amy said something like he would
Breeze through scenes like a Dance I
mean she's very poetic great singer and
Dancer total showman contagious laugh
never broke character I'm the
opposite that's all I kept thinking it's
like yeah well I I mean I always would
goof around and stuff and when the
camera when they'd say action I'm very
yeah into it but I I would break and
stuff like that um and she said even
though he was in every scene doing
stunts rehearsing songs emotional scenes
he always made time to dance with me in
between Texs is that true do you
remember that yeah I do and not that I
made time for her it's that Amy if
anyone knows Amy I do they know that
she's a little bit like a little kid
that's like pulling on your sleeve going
let's do something let's do something
and that was kind of like her energy you
know in between scenes and I I found a
way to kind of like I guess amuse that
or kind of indulge that which was to was
which was to learn dances with her for
no specific reason there was no kind of
like end of show like we're going to do
a show and tell of the dance moves we're
doing we just would learn some
choreography for the sake of it we did
have to do it for the show at one point
and that was like we felt like two
competition winners it was brilliant so
you're a Dan you you're a dancer I mean
I was never forly trained in dancing but
we did a bit of it uh at drama school
and it's always something that I have
enjoyed I guess I mean I'm I guess I've
Got Rhythm cuz I was a drummer and a
musician um growing it natural to you
did you pick it up pretty quickly Pretty
Natural to me yeah cuz when you started
young age it's a lot easier isn't it
yeah yeah for sure but I'm not like it's
not like I'm like fully disciplined in
in in dance but I I can pick it up like
if I was to do one of those shows where
they where they teach you to dance for a
few weeks you could do it probably like
Dancing with the Stars you never do that
no I was approached I was approached
quite heavily in the UK to do their
version of it um we give you lots of
money which they don't no they don't
give you lots of money and it's just no
I just I would love to do it if there
was no TV cameras there I would love to
have that one-on-one training and that
kind of you know learn that discipline
that would be amazing cuz you're would
you say you're a bit of an introvert or
a shy person with like uh you know you
could be fun and all these things but
are you sort of a private person I've
gotten more private as I've gotten older
um I think that I think that I'm an
extrovert because I get energy I get
energized from other people um my wife
and my mom think that I am an
extroverted introvert yeah um I don't
know I mean I I feel like I've certainly
changed as I've gotten older um being in
the public eye as well like the more
you're in the public eye the less you
want to give yeah because you just feel
like everyone just wants a piece of you
and like things like social media and
stuff it just you're constantly putting
yourself out there um and you know with
kids and and other things in my life I'm
like I I don't want to be so transparent
anymore I do miss the days I remember
growing up and going to drama school and
stuff and people used to talk about the
the most wonderful gift for an actor was
to have
anonymity because then people can buy
into any character that you're playing
and these days it seems to have been a
seismic shift the other way where it's
like you're doing you know you're in a
show or you're doing a film and they
want you to be on social media all the
time push push push push push but not in
the character in the film but as you and
and you feel like you're giving that
away I feel like yeah you're giving away
like your tricks basically you're giving
away your energy the thing that you
bring bring to a character um is unique
to what you have inside of you and the
more you give of of yourself I feel like
the less people can make that
differentiation right and like for
example people have a hard time if I
play an American character um not cuz my
dialect is bad I think but mainly
because they think oh it's weird cuz
you're British and like we're used to
you talking this certain way and I just
can't do that thing it's like for me
that's a frustrating kind of reaction
cuz it's like but I'm an actor so my job
is to embody whoever it is I'm playing
and for you to believe that yeah because
in the old days I mean I'm talking like
early 2000s before cell
phones you if they saw an English actor
playing a role they they don't know if
he's English they don't know if he's
American they don't so there's a mystery
of it all yeah but with social media
it's kind of uh it's erased that mystery
mhm and I mean all my cards are out on
the table I mean Jesus man everybody's
like oh yeah it's frozen bom oh he's
doing an English accent not very good
brother you know so yeah I I can
understand
that this episode is sponsored by better
help guys better help has been uh my
sponsor for quite some time and uh it's
it's a real great fit because you know
we talk about mental health constantly
on this podcast and I think it's so
important to talk to someone if I could
only get some of my family members to
talk to better help I'm working on it
I'm really working on it look around new
years's we get obsessed with how to
change ourselves instead of just
expanding on what we're already doing
right uh maybe you finally organized one
part of your space and you want to
tackle another or maybe you're taking
your supplements every morning and now
you want to actually eat breakfast too
whatever your goals for the new year
therapy helps you find your strengths so
you can ditch the extreme resolutions
and make changes that really stick
that's key because every year I write my
New Year's resolution out and some of
them are just I'm putting so much
pressure in myself to accomplish these
things you know what I mean like you
have to do this you have to do this but
I like talking to someone and talking
through things so you can get an
objective point of view from a
professional about what they think and
what they see and they have a lot of
insight to help you um if you're
thinking of starting therapy I want you
to give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
even if you've added some new routines
in your life just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
any time for no additional cost so if
you don't like your therapist which
happens there's there's no complications
you just change your therapist like that
why wait for a new year when you can
celebrate you and the changes you've
already made right now now therapy from
better help can get you there and help
you love you love the journey love this
new year visit betterhelp.com insid toay
to get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com inside of you is brought to you
by rocket
money uh rocket money I don't know why
everyone Ryan doesn't have this app this
is absolutely something you want to save
money this is you just get this app
that's it you're gonna you're G to save
money I've already saved hundreds of
dollars on Rocket money look I'll make
it simple did did you find any
subscriptions Ryan that you forgot about
or any any you paid for twice and didn't
realize it oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
like you want to watch a show and you
get that um streamer but then you don't
and then and then sometimes you open up
an appp you're like oh I'm already
paying for this uh oh how many how many
others am I paying for Rocket money is a
personal finance app app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps lower
your bills I can see all of my
subscriptions in one place and if I see
something I don't want I cancel it with
a tap I never have to get on the phone
with customer service again you guys
ever feel like money is just flying out
of your account and you have no idea
where it's going well I do I know it's
all those subscriptions think about it
between streaming services fitness apps
delivery services parenting apps it's
endless all guilty of this so I used
rocket money to help me find out what
subscriptions I'm actually spending
money on it was I opening and I had them
cancel the ones I didn't want anymore
and I feel so much better about that
because there you know it feels like
everyone's out to get you and it feels
like rocket money is out to help you and
it's very very simple with rocket money
they'll even try to get you a refund for
the last couple months of wasted money
and negotiate to to lower your bills for
you by up to 20% all you have to do is
take a picture of your bill and Rocket
money takes care of the rest it's pretty
darn simple rocket money has over 5
million users and has helped saved its
members an average of
$720 a year with over $500 million in
cancelled subscriptions stop wasting
money on things you don't use cancel
your unwanted subscriptions by going to
rocket.com inside listen to Ryan that's
rocket
money.com inside rocket
money.com
inside and a lot of people will say that
the um what's the word like you know the
the old school actors the the old the
old um you know the Harrison Fords the
real movie stars there aren't many
around anymore do you agree with that I
do actually to a certain extent and I I
the weird thing is that the Stars the
movie stars don't tend to have an awful
lot of range within their performances
apart from a select few that would be
known as character actors right but like
people like Tom Cruz who I think is
still one of the you know few movie
stars out there now Brad Pit you know
they're very similar when you going to
see Tom Cruz or Brad P you kind of know
what you're going to get but you don't
care cuz they're a [__] Star right
and uh and then you get the kind of tear
down from that um and that used to be
that you could play whatever role was
given to to you um but now it seems like
people if they know too much about you
they have a real hard time buying into
that range yeah I I guess that could be
a little upsetting do you do a lot of
dialects like a lot of uh I mean CU
you're you know born in Wales moved to
Cardiff I mean what are the ones that
you have if you could jump into for a
role at any time you think the UK is
quite an interesting place such a small
place so many different dialects and you
you're talking about like moving 20 mi
up the road and the dialect has changed
crazy and so you know growing up in that
sort of Melting Pot uh it was it was a a
skill I guess that I had um and I
realized when I got to drama school not
everyone had that same skill and I think
it's like a musical ear or something
good ear yeah yeah but it's just um yeah
a dialect work is something I've I've
always done you know when I did my first
kind of like big roll out here I was
American in it were you nervous about it
at
all
I I was to a certain extent but I was
also in a sort of being it's a bit like
sport it's a confidence-based industry
yeah and so I I had just literally
finished doing a play in London where we
it was an American play um and I was
part of this American family in the play
and we had an American director um and
American dialect coach and so I very
much felt confident about being American
at that moment in time and so when this
this audition came up and I had to make
a tape for it I didn't have those qualms
I didn't have those self-doubt things I
just kind of went for it um and then
subsequently got the role and then made
a decision that I the younger me would
have gone oh my God you've turned into
one of those actors but actually I
appreciate now why I did it when we were
shooting I get picked up in the morning
and dropped off at night and from the
moment I got picked up to the moment I
got dropped off I would stay in dialect
I'd still be Tom yeah to a certain
extent I wouldn't be the character but I
kept the American dialect up because it
was easier for me to do that to then not
think to then not be judging myself like
I sort of was a bit like oh you're a bit
of a dick for a few days for doing this
but actually it worked for me it worked
on my behalf and and it made the job
easier for me in that regard right where
where am I from right now when you're
dealing with an industry like this you
have to have a great ego
and Francis for Copa has an EO the size
of San
Francisco so you are from America doing
an
English wait wait let me do it better
when you're dealing with an industry
like this you have to have a great ego
is that a better at allll there is
actually your your dialect there is kind
of like London around the London area
home that's Gary Oldman in an interview
once yeah I I don't try to do the
English accent the that's good though if
I could just stay there
yeah I mean I use that as your starting
point cuz I think I feel like a lot of
American actors that I've worked with
when they try and do a British accent
they fail miserably why that's the thing
I can't understand cuz that you know
what is maybe they're trying to do a
different voice and not their own I
think that's what it is cuz if I'm like
talking like this I should just talk you
know talk like this like I'm talking but
if I start going yeah everything is like
this now and I'm talking like that I'm a
different person it becomes like a
caricature as opposed to that being that
person I I always remember about that
play that I was doing before I came over
here the America the American director
at one point about two weeks into
rehearsals it was like guys stop stop
stop stop stop okay you all have to stop
being British actors with American
dialect and you have to start being
American wow and we were like who What
on earth does that
mean and he was he went on to explain
that you know it's not just about
putting on a voice it's about
you know certainly Americans compared to
British it's is an attitude difference
there's a kind of like there's a an
overall energy the way you articulate
and gesticulate and stuff it's not just
about doing a voice what's a what's a a
a word or something that it's the if you
ever watch your performance youo I heard
something in there oh let me think about
I heard I heard a little Eng British
there's a few uh there's a few ones one
is the um in is in so like I've I've
been here Americans I've been here I've
been here but the bean and the bin is a
big giveaway for me uh have you done
that before I've done that before I've
been picked up on it I remember a voice
coach picking me up on it I was like God
I remember that one go remember that one
um
sure sure you like sure you sure sure is
a kind of thing cuz you can also say
sure sure uh sure but sure and sure um
two ones that you can use but you've got
to be consistent with the one you're
doing right um I'm trying to think off
the top of my head uh but those are good
ones
yeah can you do an Irish accent pretty
easily uh yeah uh where from Northern or
Southern Northern um so your man from
Belfast there he you know I had a couple
of meets from Belfast when I was at
Glasgow and you know it's it's all up in
here and in your yeah up there you know
and your man over there it's like really
putting on things like that you know and
Scotch more from the back of your throat
uh Scots Scots is back there GL go is
all all back there and um the difference
between like Glasgow on the west coast
and Edinburgh on the East Coast
Edinburgh is a we bit more sing song e
it's so we bit more like floaty in the
clouds and stuff like that you know you
can whereas glasgow's like [__] down
here and you know people talking to each
other and [__] seeing you big
wank you sheep stealing Hur and bastard
exactly uh who's who who is your
favorite actors growing
up uh so the I there's probably two or
three right um I would say Ken branner
without a shadow of a doubt wow he was
someone that made Shakespeare make sense
for me which was a big deal when I was
at school because we had you know we had
to do it as English literature as part
of our you know basic schooling in the
UK and I remember reading Romeo and
Juliet when I was like 13 Going what on
Earth is everyone on about I just
couldn't didn't have a clue um and then
I remember he did a movie of much to do
about nothing um and I watched it it was
him and Emma Thompson playing Benedict
and beis and they were just so Kenneth
Brana BR you see Brana Brana yeah Brana
Brana uh I was I used to say American I
was like Kenneth branck is a really good
actor bran Bran's a really good you
pronounce the a ug G
bran is it like Laura Branan remember
Laura Branan the singer no who's that
she's saying um Gloria Gloria oh I think
they got that was Laura brand again yeah
yeah yeah um so yeah so him K BR for
sure I just I just his Ease on on screen
and that I think that's the thing about
actors that I like you feel at ease in
their company when you're watching them
have you worked with him I've never
worked have you met him never met him
you'd love that I would love it I would
love it um I think he's wonderful and
again a proper actor incredible range
you see him play other parts you see him
play he's he's just brilliant at
everything he does um Tom Hanks yeah big
influence on me I just I loved him loved
watching him loved all his
movies um and then as I sort of evolved
and um started to think about acting
myself there's a stage actor in the UK
who's now done a lot of screen work
called Mark Ryland who was just
unbelievable when you watch him on stage
Mark Ryland unbelievable he's in I think
the most famous thing he's done over
here was probably Bridge of
spies Tom Hanks with Tom Hanks yeah um
and uh I know I know the wrer of that
movie actually and we I we were chatting
about it I was like you were onet with
Tom Hanks and Mark Ryland what was it
like he said I was literally pinching
myself every day couldn't believe it um
but I think those certainly those three
people um and then you know actresses
wise I think Emma Thompson I've always
loved brilliant always always loved her
and of course Dame Merill stre oh it's
just or Judy Dench or Judy Dench but I I
love Judy Dench but you like but I think
I remember watching Kramer versus Kramer
for the first time man both of them in
that movie were just Dustin electric
yeah it was now you say these are all
your favorite actors actresses I think
actors you just say actors now don't you
but do you like would you be nervous
working with them and do you get nervous
while you're working do you get the
nerves are you so confident that you're
you don't you learn you learn lines easy
you uh is the the process or process as
the Canadians say I mean do you like is
it do you still get nerves do you still
get nervous about stuff for sure I mean
I think the biggest gift that happened
in the last few years to me was was
doing the show Lucifer and being that
character for like six seven years and
going to that same set every time and
time on set was just like Priceless it
is and I think that you know that
certainly took my confidence to a
different place I didn't feel
um uh like I think there there's a lot
of imposter syndrome that happens in
acting I know and and I I used to feel
that all the time because you go from
job to job to job to job and every time
you start a job I think my biggest
pressure that I would have on myself is
I just want the other actors in this to
think I'm a good actor yeah and um I I
think I still you know I think every
actor still probably has that yeah but
if you've been if you're going back to a
place repeatedly you lose that um and
you just sort of I don't want to use the
word autopilot but you go into a a
comfort zone where you know the
character so well that you are not
second guessing any choices um and
you're just you're just doing and being
which is the perfect state to act in
right but the second you get another
part that's different it starts over
again doesn't we had a weird experience
actually on the penultimate season of
Lucifer because I played they asked me
to play my twin brother in it as well um
and so I was you know trying to sort of
make some differences between these
characters um with the small amount of
time that I had to did you change your
voice I did well I I gave him an
American dialect um I changed his
physicality slightly um and I remember
like being on the set and I you know all
these people I worked with for 5 years
and then I had to do this character for
the first time and that's when I felt
like the Imposter syndrome kicking in
cuz I was like you get the tingle people
are not going to buy this you know lots
of
self-doubt um but thankfully people that
around me that I knew were not judging
me specifically and um I just you know
you just have to go it in in those
circumstances yeah were you uh I haden't
felt like that for a long time really I
just think you know in this household
and growing up with the church and all
these things but again Progressive you
know and you were playing music and all
that were your parents a surprised that
you went into theater were they a little
bit worried about it did they were they
you have Their
Blessings how did they feel was your dad
hoping you'd get more into the church I
think my dad probably realized very
early on in my life that I was not going
to follow in his footsteps um cuz you
told him yeah basically I'm not doing
this because it used to be a question I
was asked a lot by people oh are you
going to follow in your father's are you
going to you know be a man of the cloth
and all those things I was like n that's
not for me um but I weirdly I I didn't
sort of I stumbled across acting really
at the end of my high schooling um I was
really into Sport and I played lots of
different sports Cricket I was into
Cricket Rugby Football when you say
football you mean soccer I mean yeah I
mean I just want to clarify for the
Americans out there not the pig skin
right right but and I just you know I
knew that I wasn't good enough at the
sports that I played to pursue them but
I still wanted to be involved in that
kind of Realm and I I decided that I was
going to get into
Physiotherapy and you know if I can't
get on the pitch as a player I can get
on the pitch to help a player sort of
thing wow um and and then I got to the
end of my high schooling in the UK the
last two years in the UK um is called
six form and you do what they call a
levels which is like you choose three
subjects that basically are are sort of
funneling your education towards what
what you want to do at University or
tertiary education most of the time that
changes of course and so I took these
three subjects and one of them was
history because I'd really enjoyed it in
my previous years at school and about
two or three weeks into it I just was
like I don't I'm not enjoying this at
all this is not the place I want to be
at so I dropped it and then my T my six
form tutors were like well you have to
do a third subject so what are you going
to do and I really didn't know and then
my old English teacher CLA came and Mr
CLA no Miss CLA Pender oh clely CLA
Pender who's a big hero of my life she
um she came and found me uh in the six
form common room and she was like Tom
I've heard you're looking for a new
subject I'm running the theater studies
class class and I've got 12 girls and
one boy at the moment I need boys and I
was like how many girls uh I'm in I'm in
and you're going on a bonding weekend
away in a week's time brilliant um so I
for all the wrong reasons like thought
oh I'll have a go at that um and I went
started doing these theater study
classes and all of a sudden it felt like
a glove that fit me and I just was
really enjoying the classes you know I I
wasn't particularly successful with any
other girls but I had a great time
working with them and and all of that
stuff and I just really got into it and
then CLA Pender again uh they were doing
a school play that year and I'd never
done a school play before um and she
wanted to cast me in the lead role for
it what role uh it was John the witch
boy in a in a show in a play called Dark
of the Moon that was set in the
Appalachian
Mountains wow I'm guessing this was not
a comedy uh no no it wasn't it wasn't um
and it and uh
and I played this this witch boy John
who fell in love with a girl called
Barbara Ellen um Barbary Allen uh and um
and from doing that a friend of mine's
mom who used to be an actress came to
see the play and she called me the day
after she came to see it and she said I
saw you in the play last night I really
think you should think about doing this
as a profession so um her and CLA my
Drama teacher both kind of really
encouraged me to audition for drama
school inside of you is brought to you
by neuro haacker qua senolytic if you
guys haven't tried this I I know you
know you hear about these things and
it's an ad and but this is something I
started taking and they weren't an
Advertiser they weren't a sponsor and I
noticed a difference in my clarity and
uh I just really want people to to
listen and uh give it a shot you know
give this a shot because this is uh this
is pretty incredible uh your life goals
in your career and Beyond require
productivity but let's be honest you're
the aging process is not our friend when
it comes to endless energy and
productivity and that's that's why a lot
of people like me use quaia cytic if
someone would have told me that there
are science-backed ingredients that
could helped me feel 15 years younger in
a matter of months I wouldn't have
believed it and then I tried Kaa cytic
as we age everyone accumulates senent
cells in their body senent cells may
cause symptoms of Aging such as aches
and pains I know I get those slow
workout recovery sluggish mental and
physical energy associated with that
middle-age feeling also known as zombie
cells they are old and worn out and not
serving a useful function for our health
anymore but they could be taking up
space and nutrients from our healthy
cells much like pruning the the
yellowing and Dead Leaves off a plant
Perfect Analogy qualia cenotic helps
remove those worn out Cent cells to
allow for the rest of them to thrive in
the body and you know what you just take
it two days a month you don't have to
take these pills every day two days a
month that's it and the formula is
non-GMO vegan glutenfree the ingredients
are meant to complement one another
factoring the combined effect of all
ingredients together it has a 100 day
money back guarantee this is really a
great product and I urge you to take
advantage of it um I've had higher
energy levels uh I I definitely feel
younger I have more clarity less aches
and pains um it it just does wonders
help resist aging at the cellular level
try qualia senolytic go to neuro
hacker.com inside for up to $100 off and
use code inside at checkout for an
additional 15% off these statements have
not been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
that's neurohacker dcom inside for an
extra 15% off your purchase thanks to
neurohacker for sponsoring today's video
inside of you is brought to you by
wondery even the Royals being a king or
queen might seem enticing but more often
than not it comes at the expense of
everything else like your freedom your
privacy and sometimes even your head the
creators of Wes even the rich are
bringing you a brand new podcast called
even the Royals
where hosts Brooke and Arisha pull back
the curtain on royal families past and
present from all over the world to show
you the darker side of what it really
means to be royalty from stories about
one of the most infamous Royals in
history Marie Antoinette but everything
you know about her is wrong after she
became Queen at just 19 years old she
ended up in a battle with the French
press that started a series of
impossible to believe events it's
History's Greatest smear campaign and it
had deadly consequences or what might be
the worst Royal marriage of all time
between King George IV and Caroline of
Brunswick it's a story involving
catfishing fake pregnancies and It All
Leads to a divorce trial where the whole
world sat on the edge of their seats to
see how it would all play out follow
even the Royals on the wry app or
wherever you get your podcasts you can
binge even the Royals ad free right now
on wondery
plus uh if they would have
said not if they hadn't said that yeah
do you think you still would have I God
good question I don't know I know there
was a girl in the play that I was doing
the play with who played Barbara Allen
and she had loved drama her entire life
and she was always going to be an
actress um and she said to me um I'm
going to go an audition for this thing
called National Youth Theater uh which
is like a summer course residential
course in London um and uh do you want
to come to the audition so I was like
that sounds fun and by this point you
know the bug had really bitten me and I
was like okay I'll give that a go and I
went to audition for this thing and I
got a place which was like really you
know really good going basically at that
stage in my very early career um and I
went down to London that summer for like
3 weeks and just met loads of people all
who wanted to do the same thing all
likeminded I just had the best time you
became a thespian I became a thespian
thespian uh and you know from that you
know loads of these people were either
already at drama school or were
auditioning for drama school the next
year and that was the thing that really
spurred me on and said right that's what
I'm going to do audition for it and then
CLA Pender spoke to my parents and said
I really think you know you just
encourag Tom and to to go and do this
because I think he's got a real chance
and they did they paid for me my train
fair to get to all these little
auditions around the country did you
book any and I got yeah I got in I got
into the Royal Scottish Academy of Music
and drama inco and that's that's where
it all you know I did three years there
and then it kind of like seamlessly
segwayed into starting to work and it
was really weird once I'd sort of
decided I wanted to be an actor and lots
of actors will hate me for this it was
kind of
seamless you know I I'm going to agree
with you with me it really was it was I
finally found something that people
responded and liked what I was doing and
it felt good this instant Gra ification
immediate I I felt like I'm doing
something right for the first time in my
life not being me is the way to go and
it just it just kept going from there
and I and I felt it probably my junior
senior year in college when I was doing
a lot of the I felt it and I remember
telling Alexis combms her sitting on her
uh doorstep and she goes are you nervous
about going to New York you know blah
and I said I want you to remember this
conversation
I'm G to make it and I know you're
thinking oh everybody says that oh
another you know I'm going to make it
this this I go no no no no just watch I
just see it I see it yeah I could feel
it I it there was a certain energy that
I had that I didn't care about the
statistics of who makes it and who
doesn't I just was so I wish I had that
now but it was just so I was so
determined but so confident in whatever
ability I had at the time and it was
crazy and did you feel that a little too
I did yeah no I did and it's it's a
strange kind of it's almost like having
a faith it's almost like you know being
really kind of religious about you know
whatever religion you're into but like
having that Comfort having that kind of
like over overwhelming feeling that
everything's going to be all right with
the decision that you've made um it's
rare it is rare and I don't know where
it came from I don't know what it was
but I do know that I always had that
feeling and even when I started
acting I always had this feeling that I
was going to work and I you know it's a
weird coming from the country that I
come from cuz people will probably
accuse you of being arrogant for saying
something like that but it wasn't it
wasn't about arrogance it was about it
was about self- belief and confidence
self because the thing is if you are
going to go into this ridiculously
competitive industry you have to believe
in yourself you have to believe that
what you have is unique and what you can
offer is different to everybody else and
it doesn't make you right or wrong or
better or worse but it's Unique and
that's the thing that you have to really
kind of hold on to it's the hardest
thing to hold on to when you're being
rejected constantly yeah but at the same
time if you're not going to back you
then no one else is were you one of
those actors or are in the beginning
where you're like I just love acting I
want to do theater I don't care about
because there's a lot of I I don't want
to do TV or movies or were you sort of
like because I was always like I want to
be in the movies I want to I love
theater I did theater and then I was
like Wow TV's kind of fun movies are fun
I just and I never went back to the
theater yeah because it's it's tedious
it's really like you know you do eight
shows a week and for me it'd be my
nerves on edge every all day every day
and I just don't think you know that's
how much I put into it and how much I
thought about it all the time but were
you someone who wanted to just act
whatever it was I mean certainly my
early experiences were only on stage um
and like going into drama school it was
just about that it was about doing
theater different types of theater but
like theater and then towards the end of
the course you know you get the odd
person that would come in and you do a
day's Workshop talking about working on
in front of camera and stuff and it's so
ridiculous looking back at it cuz the
reality is if you go to drama school
when you come out of drama school
probably about at least 75% of your work
is going to be on
screen um and I I hadn't really thought
about that side of it
I I know that I loved theater but I was
really open to all of it I remember
someone coming into drama school to like
to just talk to us as final year
students and saying your first couple of
years out of here take whatever comes in
your direction don't be picky don't be
this don't be that just take what comes
and and it's exactly what I did and I
learned you know that I enjoy you know
working on camera I I enjoy being on set
um and I still love going to the theater
and I still love being part of a play
and um as the years have gone on you
know I've done probably three
professional plays in 20 nearly 25 years
wow and the rest of it has been camera
work um and that's not necessarily by
choice cuz one thing I do know is that I
will always go back to the theater I'm
I'm at a stage now where I'm like
plotting when that's going to happen
next but for me as an actor I kind of
feel like theater is like rehab for
acting when you've done a lot of work on
set and on screen um you you you know
things like the rehearsal room and that
space for like four weeks it feels like
a gift these days because you have zero
rehearsal time when you when you're
certainly when you're doing a TV show
you really you rehearse on the day and
then you know for like 20 minutes and
then you show it to a crew and it's like
this is how we're doing it and you have
to have made a lot of choices and
decisions and things before you even got
there whereas that exploratory sort of
you know going into the rehearsal room
finding things trying things out
building it all from the ground up and
then presenting it um and then having
the immediate audience you know
gratification if you're in a comedy
getting a laugh is like the biggest
thing in the world I love that side of
it absolutely but then I remember the
grind I remember like doing the eight
shows a week and you know you're in a
theater production you're like Jesus how
long have we got left another six weeks
am going do that thing day and day out
yeah so you know like every actor never
pleased never happy never never fully
satisfied yeah but I love all of it and
I'm glad that I started in the theater
yeah that's good anybody you worked with
or went to school with um have they had
success oh sure I mean my best friend at
drama or one of had sort of a circle of
very tight friends at drama school um
but one of them was James maoy oh wow I
don't know if You' heard of him but yes
I have heard of James maoy and we're
still you know really good mates we
don't see each other as much as we used
to cuz you know we live in different
sides of the world you with him on stage
oh yeah I did my first ever professional
gig with James which was a panto a
pantomim sorry in uh in kadei in faith
in Scotland uh it was our final year of
drama school and the drama school were
doing a pantomim because that's a big
thing in the UK um and but they said to
any final year students if you want to
audition for any professional pantos
you're allowed to do that so James and I
both auditioned for this panto Beauty
and the Beast and we both got it and so
and it was a musical it was music pantos
have always got music in them yeah
pantos I didn't know that and uh and
they've always got like they' they've
always got like stock characters in them
whatever the story is that year what
it's always a fairy tale do you still
remember the the songs the music the all
that fire were Bell which is from I
can't remember that which musical that's
from originally but that was in R1 I
remember my song that I had to do was a
um A House Is Not a Home a chair is
still a chair Bert
barar house is not is that right a chair
is still a chair even if there's no one
sitting there that's amazing um and yeah
so weird did you always have that like
ear for like being on key is that
something that you're born with because
I I I A lot of times I have a band and
sunspin and you know I'll I'll say you
know a home is not a home and my Rob go
off key smile smile smile when you're
saying a home is not a home not in every
line why an English accent a home is not
a home you know what I mean so I don't
but I have to work at it and I have to
really learn I don't have that ear I
could sort of I sort of do but well I
wouldn't say I wouldn't say I've got
Perfect Pitch by any stretch of the
imagination but I you know my mom was a
a music teacher a there you go and so we
all in my family you know music was
around us all the time and we were for
want of a better word lumbered with
instruments that our parents chose for
us as we were growing up so I played I
started on the Cornet when I was 5 years
old cornet which the Cornet which is a
small trumpet yeah and then moved up to
the trumpet when my hands got a bit
bigger and then then this is giving
insight to my parents they made an
executive decision on my behalf when I
was 9 years old that I should change
from the trumpet to the French horn cuz
it would give me more opportunities in
life oh my God that's how your
parents oh my God that's
brilliant so um we believe the French
horn is going to get you more
work are you are you [__]
crazy um so yeah so you did that you
played the French horn play the French
horn you play guitar too by the way yeah
I I I'm sort of a self-taught guitarist
so I don't know I don't know the guitar
in and out I again that if my parents I
go back and my parents gave me a choice
about instruments knowing what I know
now guar I would have said guitar and
piano stick me on nose and the rest will
take care of itself cuz I'm always
envious of anyone that can sit a piano
and just I know I'd like to learn but I
think it's too late now isn't it I mean
to be a Pianist I just wanted to say
that word it's too late to be a
Pianist
um it's ridiculous it's too late to be a
Pianist it's to too
late who sings that song actually uh
it's too late to come from my uh too
late who it One Republic One Republic
nice Ryan nice Ryan without a microphone
thank you Ryan um thank thank you Ryan
you really out did yourself that's what
I'm here for yeah I'm projecting good
he's projecting he's got no microphone
cuz he's Private Ryan yes he's Private
Ryan there we go we should save him from
the rest of this
conversation Saving Private Ryan
um what an idiot I like stupid jokes I
like Dad jokes I love dad jokes what's
your favorite dad joke um two fish in a
tank one says to the other so how do you
drive this
thing that's good
yeah oh my my uh my daughter my youngest
daughter man has all got an incredible
sense of humor she came back from a
school Camp the other I've got to say
this cuz it just made me laugh so much
she came back from a school Camp the
other week and she said dad I told that
joke you told me years ago and the
teachers loved it and I was like what
was the joke and she went you know
what's the difference between a Range
Rover and a
hedgehog with a hedgehog the Pricks are
on the
outside like you that your teach my God
that's awesome she was yeah they loved
it oh so the Pricks are on the
outside it's so true no if you're
driving a rain
dver um we got to get into loose for a
little bit okay
um I mean what a huge success and like a
huge fan base like I remember watching
that it was Netflix when Netflix took
over first of all how rare is it for a
show to where Fox said they didn't want
to go on and yet they found a home at
Netflix that that just doesn't happen MH
usually a show's over it's over well
we'll take the five seasons and we'll
error those and they wanted another
season out of it right well we'd done by
that point we'd done three seasons just
three yeah we've done and the first
season was like what they call like a
half season so it was 13 episodes and
then we did two of the full you know 22
Episodes biggies and then they cancelled
it how how did you feel by the way when
that happened oh I honestly I was gutted
I was I was I was at a fan convention in
Rome having the time of my life and like
having you know spent a whole weekend of
people just confessing their love for
the show and like talking about the show
and blah blah blah and it was you know I
was thousands of miles from where we'd
film this thing thinking my goodness
isn't it strange that we'd like we've
got this fan base is growing and growing
and growing and growing and then
literally I was in the minib buus on the
way back from the convention to the
hotel we were staying at and I got a
call from our showrunner saying that fox
had just canceled the
show uh and I just I was crushed I like
I was so like I was thrown I just didn't
I I didn't expect it to happen and I was
I was yeah I was pretty devastated I'm
not going to lie did you have to do a
Q&A after that no that was I so I just
done I think I just done my last day uh
thank God I know how are you keep it
straight face like yeah I hope it goes
forever too I know well the whole
weekend had been about people going when
are we going to hear about season 4 when
are we going to hear about season 4 and
I was like very soon very soon don't
worry and then I got the call and it was
like oh my god um but how long after did
you get the call saying hey they're
trying to get this going here's the
weird thing so I I traveled back to
London uh from Rome and I was just you
know gutted and I was talking to people
on the phone and whatever and then I
found out that that that was on like the
Monday or Tuesday and I found out out
that fox still hadn't announced that
they were canceled it yet um so we knew
but no one else knew and then uh then
someone tipped me off I'm not going to
say who but someone tipped me off that
fox had planned to kind of bury the news
of the cancellation by announcing
something else at the same time uh that
following weekend Oh were there a new
show replacing Lucifer and any yeah yeah
all of that and I was you know I had a
lot of emotion going on a lot of these
things and I decided that I would take
it upon myself to tweet that I had found
out the show had been cancelled and I
was absolutely gutted and I'm sorry to
everyone and I did that good move I did
that before the announcement before the
announcement were they pissed I don't
[__] care yeah I mean to be honest
with you at the time they fired you you
know what I pressed send on that tweet
and then I had a panic attack cuzz I
thought oh my god I've just like ruined
everything and blah
right inside of you is brought to you by
discover if you like using debit over
credit don't you think it's time you
also get rewarded well now you can with
discover cashback debit it's a checking
account that rewards everyone with cash
back on everyday purchases plus there
are no fees period we're talking date
nights thrifting the latest trends
nights out with your friends and it's
now earning you cashback with discover
cashback debit check out eligibility and
terms at discover.com
slashback deit Discover Bank member FDIC
does your beloved Pooch have a not so
secret problem bad doggy breath not to
worry introducing my very own Rosy's
puppy fresh breath just a splash in your
dog's water bowl and Rosy's puppy fresh
breath Works its magic neutralizing bad
breath reducing harder and promoting
better dental health vet approved made
with natural ingredients and works to
solve what causes bad breath in dogs
Rosy's puppy fresh breath because every
tail wagging moment should be fresh and
enjoyable get yours today on
Amazon uh and I I left my phone and I
went uh into my room and I was just like
what have I done uh blah blah blah and
then I got my [__] together and about an
hour and a half later I went back to my
phone and I looked at it and it had
absolutely blown up but it had blown up
in the most positive way possible and
this kind of I I've said it before
there's like tsunami of love just came
from around the world from all these
people hundreds of thousands it was
crazy and it didn't stop that was the
thing about it it just snowboard and
snowboard and snowboard and snowboard
and uh eventually I got a call later
that weekend from a guy called Peter
Roth who was head head of Warner
Brothers TV who Warner Brothers was our
studio and they made it for Fox um and
he said Tom um like I want you to know
we're not ignoring all this kind of all
this stuff that's happening on on social
media um we are going to try and do
something about it um and so I said what
do you need me to do and he said uh can
you get over here to La um you know just
to keep keep it kind of keep stoking the
fire as it was so I got on I I got
myself to Heath airport and then I got
to Heath airport I had a a message from
BBC News night now if anyone knows
that's big the UK there's the news and
then BBC News night is a night is a
nightly show that discusses the news in
a very very kind of like intellectual
you know articulate way 60 minutes yeah
basically and they said that they had
noticed that they had been you know
noticing what was happening on social
media and blah blah blah about the show
did I want to appear as a guest on the
show to talk about that and to talk
about television changing and all these
things and I was like absolutely so I
got to LA and then I ended up doing like
a a studio bit back to London about this
and for the next kind of week and a half
two weeks it just like this became like
all I talked about and all people were
asking me about um and then you know a
couple weeks later I I'd sort of been
tipped off from Peter that that things
were progressing well and then we got
the Netflix announcement and it was the
most vindicating wonderful
experience and I didn't feel quite so
bad press about pressing send on that
tweet you single-handedly did that you
single-handedly brought back the show I
no I mean the the the crazy thing is
that I I'd already I already knew from
like 3 years of doing press for the show
that it really kind of started to spread
that people were loving this show and
not just in in the States but like
everywhere I was going to and weirdly
now when I look back at it lots of
Catholic countries all the countries
around the world that are Catholic are
really into the show don't know why but
there we go right um but um well they're
fascinated by that kind of stuff they
are yeah they're fascinated by that
character and you know you know what the
their perception of the devil is and
what ours was and but it was it was when
I heard it had been cancelled I thought
oh there's a lot of people who aren't
going to be very happy about this what I
didn't realize Iz that there was
millions of people that were not happy
about it and wouldn't let it go and it
was I you know eduse the word
vindicating again but it really was kind
of like I I didn't I I wanted to think
I'm not going crazy like I'm doing all
this press around the world for the
first few years I've been involved in
things before and I know when
something's popular and this felt
incredibly popular but it didn't feel
like Fox ever recognized that for
whatever reason I don't know um but it
was popular and then it just grew and
grew once it went on Netflix it just
exploded were you the one who told the
rest of the cast or they already knew uh
I so people have been calling me saying
do you know what's going on do you know
what's going on and I said Amy yeah Amy
uh I just tell Amy then she tell
everyone else yeah um I and I was
basically like look I Warner Brothers
are trying to find a new home for it
that's what I know and as soon as I know
anything else I'll let you know but
until then just keep you know keep
plugging away keep responding on Twitter
keep telling people to keep the faith as
it were um you know we're not going down
we're not going to just lie down and
take it sort of thing um that's
beautiful just never happens yeah and
and again you know I've been told by
Peter Roth and other people this never
happens this never happens this never
happens but that weird sort of feeling
that you were talking about before about
your career and the same thing that I'd
had I'd had this kind of niggle that
something was going to happen about it
and
and it did you
know I'll bring this back to
me um I had a show that got cancelled in
two seasons and and the ratings if they
were now it would have been a big show
like the ratings were pretty good they
were decent they weren't you know but
now if we had those ratings that show
would get five six seasons and we just
got two but I remember you know the head
called me and he was awesome love Keith
Cox and Keith was like hey we're going
more female Centric and you know we're
not going to do the show anymore so I
was like ah okay and then I uh called
the other producer and the Creator and
producer's like C is can we find another
home for it ah I don't know no one it
just went away and by the way I didn't
get millions of people going oh my God
it was like you know 300 300 people
saying hey really that sucks I like that
[__] you know but I even then I had some
hope going hey you know this was it's a
pretty fun show maybe but the fact that
the response so in a you know as much as
we could sit there and say I hate social
media I hate you know we all do it we're
Hypocrites and we do it yet there's so
many bad facets of of social media but
they're good facets you know they're
good parts to it and you know this
without social media this wouldn't have
happened oh no without a shadow of a and
I I'm the same as you I have hugely
mixed feelings about social
and I I again you know the more you're
in the spotlight the less you want to
use it is my feeling about it like I
just I want to be private um and protect
things privately and I think feel like
going on social media you're just
leaving yourself open to anything um and
but at the same time I wouldn't be here
probably talking to you about this thing
right now if it hadn't been for social
media there are huge positives to it
yeah um but you know I remember watching
an interview with David Bowie back in 97
I think it was and on BBC News night and
he was talking about the internet and he
was talking about what an incredibly
amazing thing it can be but also at the
same time what an incredibly what what a
what a window of Darkness it will open
as well absolutely and that's you know
I'd say the same thing about social
media yep would you do a
Lucifer Revival if they said let's do a
movie we want to do a movie a two-hour
movie or one final thing is it something
you would strongly consider or you think
hey this is let's put this to the rest I
certainly feel like on the TV front
we've we've like I said before we
covered all
bases um I think that the only thing
that would make me go back would be if
it were a movie um and it would have to
be good that you know it's not just
doing it for the sake of doing it it
would have to be you know we'd have to
sign off on like what the script was and
all those things because I feel like one
of the one of the things that one of the
weird things certainly about working
over here is there's so much like when
you're somebody successful people just
want more more more more more whereas
where I'm from you know leave them
wanting more is the motto and it was
never such a sort of financially
commercially based industry back in the
UK yeah so you don't you know Miranda
for example we only ever did 20 episodes
in
total and it's still I iconic and it
still has a an afterlife that people
revisit um but the reason we only did
that many is cuz Miranda didn't want to
do anymore and she didn't want to write
any because it took so much out but she
wrote all the episodes of it and she
felt like she'd done it and you know to
beat it around the head and dilute it as
a product just for the sake of making
more and more and more and more she
didn't want to do that and I had so much
respect for her for making that decision
cuz the BBC were desperate for it wow um
and I you know I I I strongly believe
that leave them wanting more yeah it's
important um when Netflix bought
Lucifer is was it sort of like hey if
you guys want this to go for another
three seasons they're going to pay what
you guys were making but they're not
going to give any advances or or those
things still worked out so because if I
were them they want the show back we're
just not paying them anymore this is
what you know that's what happened I
figured that that's Happ that's what
happened we uh you know without getting
into it too much I I stayed on the same
contract for the whole time yeah um
which you know
I I you weren't happy about it I wasn't
happy about it and is the reason that
this you know this the strike and
everything has happened and all those
things like is to address the situation
that I found myself in at the end of
Lucifer um and I'm not complaining about
it but I am glad that we are now as a
union doing something about those
situations never happening again yeah um
because I think people assume that it
because it's so uccessful now on Netflix
people assume that I am rich beyond my
worldest dreams which I am not uh and uh
I you know it's just it's one of those
things but I I'm glad you know one of
the great things about being over here
as an actor is that the union is
incredibly strong and um you know the
the St the steps that they've been going
through uh recently um is is really
really important and unfortunately for
me I would say something that would
never happen back home
um because the union isn't strong enough
and you know one of the things I I think
universally in this industry is we are
always made to feel how lucky we are to
be working and I think I think the
payers sort of use that to their
advantage you're an actor you're a
working actor you're a working actor you
you should be you know lucky lucky lucky
and it's like I agree with you but at a
certain point it's also my career and my
you know this is how I support my family
my livelihood my livelihood
so you know I need it to be treated that
way as well not just to kind of like you
look how lucky you are cuz I don't you
know I feel incredibly lucky that this
is all happening for me yeah but I also
you know this is that's the chance I
took that's the chance I took when I
started my career and you know like
anything in life in success you would
like to be
rewarded well I always say if you're an
integral part of something that becomes
successful and you're an integral part
of that you absolutely deserve to be
paid compensated MH I I I don't
understand why there's why there's
always oh we're not making it there's
always a reason there's always a reason
and we don't have to get into that but
you know it's certainly as an artist as
a creative as well I feel like that that
is just you know your your work outlives
you um but to just be paid to do the
work then and then everyone else sort of
like sees that work and you know people
start to gravitate towards it
there needs to be some kind of like
Equitable way of of working it out yeah
just yeah it can't be just like well we
don't know yeah we don't know how it's
it's getting a lot of views we can't how
do we differentiate I mean I think they
do know they know I think that's the
thing it's just like that you know they
worked on a business model that all of a
sudden well not all of a sudden I think
over time that business model has
created what it's created and now people
have gone well the the the language that
we're using is not not relevant to this
business model but the job that we're
doing is exactly the same yeah so we we
need to catch up and you know what's
next uh anything that you're looking
forward to yeah I mean I I shot
something last year uh called Washington
black for Hulu um which is an adaptation
of a of a wonderful novel of the same
name um and it it's a big extravagant
costume drama um set at the time of the
end towards the end of slavery in the
British British Empire it's a nine-part
limited series wow uh with Sterling K
Brown wow um and whole host of other
wonderful people Charles Dance played my
dad in it which was incredible
experience um and I'm really looking
I've not seen a frame of it yet not a
frame I haven't seen anything have you
heard he's really great in
it a couple of people have told me that
that I know a Hulu um which is lovely
but I you know as an actor you're like
whatever everybody will say that let's
watch I'm sure it's great but I'm really
looking forward to that coming out and
then my wife and I are working together
um on a couple of projects uh and that
is basically something that I'm really
looking forward to doing because I we
worked together once before I had a
great experience she's an incredible
writer right and you know I'm at a point
in my life where spinning lots of plates
about family and geography and things
like that to be able to you know take
that out of the equation on projects and
still deliver something that's really
good yeah um feels like a huge sort of
benefit so yeah is it Megan or Megan
Megan like like Reagan I say it wrong
all the time my kids say it wrong all
time Megan like Reagan Megan mea G ha
and I mean you get this a million but it
really is Oppenheimer it is and she is
related
too how so I believe it is uh her it's
so it it be a cousin cuz it's a great
uncle's son so a long distance cousin
there you go so what did you think what
she saw
it we haven't seen it yet oh well well
there you go no no for no particular
reason I've heard it's incredible um I
just you know we are not the best to be
perfectly fair at getting to the theer
the movies darling they maybe I'll
screen it here one night it should do I
do want to watch still do want to watch
it on IMAX though cuz I know you're
meant to watch it that I did I watched
on that I've got a terrible habit of
watching movies that I should have
watched on IMAX but on planes yeah yeah
I know I watched avatar for the first
time on the back of a night in a a coach
seat you know those tiny little monitors
hey do you do like lastly do you do any
Impressions oh do I do any
Impressions um actually I I sort of I
worked on my Charles Dance a little bit
when I was working with him you know he
was um he was in Game of Thrones which
one was he he's uh Lannister the the the
dad Lannister oh he's amazing yeah so
Char I'm going to close my eyes so you
know he he would be talking a lot of the
time and um it feel like he was cleaning
cleaning stuff from his teeth all the
time Tom but um do you go to the gym Tom
are you one of those
actors yes is that what he does yeah
that's amazing he got this kind of like
disapproving snil all the time but I I
thankfully I got to know him really well
and he's a teddy bear underneath all
gosh he was so intimidating and he died
on the [__] oh yeah he died on the
[__] yeah him and Elvis Elvis yeah no
I kind he he is incredibly intimidating
and again one of those people when I
started working with him I was like my
inner voice just going I just want you
to think I'm a good actor um I know we
all want that we all deep down want
somebody to go that he was really great
he was great to work with he was you
want a few things you want somebody you
want to be likable you want to be uh
giving to your fellow actor you want to
um you know you just sometimes like I
worked with this guy Bill fitner you
know him I don't know that you know him
if you saw him he's been in everything
um but he wanted to meet me before they
cast me in this movie I did like four
years
ago I was like [__] so the director's
like he wants to have lunch with you
someone and had lunch with him and he
was just kind of really dry and you know
talked to me and and then afterwards the
director said hey he thought you were
really nice was like Oh I thought he was
going to be like I don't want to work
with this guy and then I worked with him
but I was always like trying to earn his
and I think by theend by in Even in our
first scene together he goes it's almost
like he sighed like he he goes okay
you're good okay you're here to play
you're good yeah that I felt it I to
prove it that is a lovely feeling it is
that is a lovely feeling a scary feeling
it's really scary and you know
intimidating and all of those things and
I think there's something about the
blessing of your peers that is
incredibly profound as an actor I don't
know what it is I know because we all
like to [__] about other people's
performances that's what it is yeah God
that sucks but uh yeah just that yeah
this has been a treat I I really thank
you for coming in you're you're a
delightful guest you're so insightful I
love the stories I love the you just
very open and um yeah well you're very
good at this Mr brosen B well thank you
very much just I appreciate this was
awesome thank you buddy yeah it's
awesome I loved him and I didn't think I
thought he'd be a little bit more shy I
think I thought he'd be a little more
reserved and he was just freaking cool
thank you Tom Ellis man I had a blast
with you uh I don't know if I'll ever
hear from you again but uh he was great
he came over the house and he was I
don't know if he did it a favor for Tom
Welling because Tom made the initial
introduction you know most the time I
get my own guest but you know a lot of
times like you know Kristen Ritter
introduced me to Ken moss and you know
uh ski and um so you have friends that
help you out you know I don't sit there
and go oh could you you know but if they
go oh I know so and so wonder I go yeah
sure whatever you can do because you
have to entertain thank you Kristen rder
little shout out to Kristen little shout
out to Tom Welling
Wellington and uh that's it man if you
didn't listen to the intro I don't know
what else to tell you join patreon today
and support the podcast uh a little more
than just listening which is awesome but
go to patreon p a o n patreon.com inside
you and uh support the podcast so we can
keep going and give you good episodes
give you good content you know sometimes
I I you know I was watching this intro
Ryan to another person's podcast and I
like the person and then I was like he
gets so many you know he gets really big
numbers and this and I was like stop it
stop comparing yourself stop comparing
yourself to this and and then I started
thinking well I think I'm a better
interviewer than that person why are
they I said I'm like
stop this person does their thing you do
your thing and some people like what you
do and people like what that I was
comparing myself and I was like no
you're not going to do that I stopped
myself I said good for that person and
good for me the world is
lucky was the longest YouTube comment
you've ever left no yeah maybe but
anyway but I I like this person and I
like their content good but sometimes it
surprises me that some people get you
know so many
viewers what are they doing I maybe I
don't uh maybe I'm not uh funny enough I
don't I'm not personable
enough you're
compelling that's good I guess so I
don't
know maybe I'm
boring am I
boring
what Ryan you
[__] h oh boy don't compare yourself
ever but I'm just admitting that I did
so sorry I won't do it again uh all
right thank you so much all my love
we're going to give a shout out to the
top tier patrons now who we love and
adore and without them we couldn't do
this podcast and here they are the first
reading of the
year make sure you join Nancy D Leah and
Kristen L Lisa Yukiko
Yukiko how would you sing Yuko as a song
yuk
go where you
want you can go where you like
youo it's like a guns and& roses bide is
that what that is like Yukiko like you
Kiko but youo you can go you can go you
go where you want to you go where you
like all right sorry Jill e Brian hin
Camp you got to go to 80s concert man
Nico P I hope uh Zachary's doing all
right Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj
C Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Mike e l Don Supremo 99 more San Diego M
lean P Ryan you want to read a couple
sure Matty s blinda and Dave H wait wait
Dave H Dave H hello Michael Dave Dave I
hope you had a nice new Dave really
really enjoyed you hopefully wait it's
I'm not doing it really well hold on
Dave oh I hope you had a good I hope you
had a good New Year Dave it's been
really nice Michael I am it's terrible
I'm sorry but Dave you're awesome go
ahead Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T
Tom n Talia M Betsy D Ranon C Corey K
Dev Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
Eugene and
Leah Cory mels Christine s Eric H and
Shane R Christine s Mel s Eric H Shane R
that's right Andrew M
Amanda R Kevin e Stephanie K jorel jam
and J Leanne J Luna R Mike F Stone H
Brian l juwels m Kendall L Jessica B
Kyle F Marisol P Marisol Kaylee J Brian
a Mari and Louise L Romeo the band Frank
B Jen T Nikki L April R Randy s jdw oral
P Oral B toothbrushes chel D Melissa H
Nick W Stephanie and Evan Charlene a Don
G Jenny B John Jennifer R Tina e ngg
Tracy
juny um do we have less top tier patrons
does it seem a little
less I don't know I'm G to count them
right now one two I'm not going to count
them but uh Hey thank you guys for
supporting the podcast um it is awesome
it is really awesome that you do that
and you continue to do so some of these
people have been here for years
supporting this podcast and I guess they
see something in it for them that helps
or they appreciate it I guess that's and
I appreciate them but to to be a patron
to give a certain amount of money every
month to something like a subscription
to like like a Hulu or whatever uh to do
that for a
podcast something's got to be going
right maybe it's they feel a family sort
of a connection um um they uh like the
content what do you think it is
Ryan uh probably all of the above could
be all the above I don't have a specific
answer I'm sorry that's okay guys thank
you for listening to the podcast today
uh thank you for allowing me to be
inside of you I hope you join us every
week I hope you hopefully you enjoyed
Tom Ellis I enjoyed Ryan right here um
and uh all my love to you from the
Hollywood Hills and Hollywood California
I am Michael rosenbom I am Ryan taes
little here too wave to the camera
you're here too Ryan I'm here too that
was so like just like I'm here too I'm
half here my brain went somewhere else
somewhere my bad it's the New Year guys
all right uh be good to yourself be good
to yourself let's do it right let's
you're going to make mistakes things are
going to happen that you're like you're
upset with yourself about you're not
keeping to your resolution to your list
to your just try to do the best you can
and try to be healthy
and uh that's all I can tell you all
right we'll uh we'll see you next week I
hope you're here and uh goodbye Ryan
goodbye
[Music]
bye